préparation des personnes condamnées
pour homosexualité entre 1942 et 1982
présenté par Monsieur Hussein Bourgi et
plusieurs de ses collègues du groupe
socialiste écologiste et
républicains dans la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Husen Bourgi
auteur de la proposition de loi pour 10
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le garde des saau monsieur le président
de la commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues j'ai
l'honneur de vous proposer cette
proposition de loi de la soumettre à vos
débats et à vos votes cette proposition
de loi dont je suis l'auteur et qui vise
à la reconnaissance et à la réparation
des personnes condamnées pour
homosexualité en France entre 1942 et
1982 je tiens à remercier les 102
collègues sénateurs et sénatriceses qui
ont cossigné cette proposition de loi je
tiens à saluer les collègues qui ont été
élus à la fin du mois de septembre qui
ont manifesté leur soutien à cette
initiative
parlementaire la diversité politique des
cignataires démontre une chose nous
traitons dans un climat apaisé d'un
sujet qui peut faire et qui doit faire
consensus cette proposition de loi est
animé par quelques idées simples la
quête de la vérité et la recherche de la
justice ce sont ces valeurs qui m'ont
servi de boussole dans le cheminement
mant conduit à la rédaction et au dépôt
de ce
texte les lois mémoriales se donnent
bien souvent pour mission de réconcilier
un pays avec son histoire en effet
l'histoire de chaque pays est faite de
part de lumière dont il convient de
tirer une légitime fierté et de part
d'ombre dont on gagne à reconnaître la
véracité l'histoire de France l'histoire
de notre pays n'échappe pas à cette
règle il s'appelait Henri de monterland
Roger pafit Michel chomara Bernard Bouss
ils étaient célèbres et sur surtout
anonyme ils aimaient la France il la
servai il l'a célébré il s'était engagé
pour certains d'entre eux dans la
résistance comme Jean Desbordes il
chantaient la France comme Charles
traîné mais avec eux comme avec des
dizaines de milliers d'hommes et des
centaines de femmes la France ne fut pas
douce elle fut au contraire cruelle la
France a dépénalisé l'homosexualité en
1791 dans le code napoléonien au
lendemain de la Révolution française
devenant un des pays les plus
progressistes en la matière nous le
devons au juriste montpellérin
Jean-Jacques régist de comambaseres
hélas sous la 3è République de grands
commis de l'État pressai le gouvernement
de sévir contre
l'homosexualité si la France a
dépénalisé l'homosexualité en
1791 devenant donc Cees pays
progressistes cette parenthèse libérale
fut de courte durée quelques années plus
tard ces grands commis de l'État vurent
leurs vœux et exaucé par le maréchal
Pétin en août 42 l'ère du temps
n'expliquera jamais ce retour en arrière
en effet à la même période en Europe la
Suède la Suisse ou encore la Pologne
décriminaliser les relations entre
personnes de même sexe à rebours de son
histoire la France instauré une majorité
sexuelle de 21 ans pour les homosexuels
contre 13 ans pour les hétérosexuel une
discriminance discrimination d'apparence
anodine mais qui légitimera jusqu'à la
fin de la guerre la persécution
l'arrestation et la condamnation de
dizaines de milliers d'hommes dans notre
pays quelques centaines d'entre eux
furent hélas déportés depuis la France
vers les camps de rééducation et de
concentration lentemps éclipsé de la
mémoire collective ce qui étit obligé de
porter le triangle rose ont été
progressivement réhabilités nous le
devons au travaux des historiens
auxquels je veux rendre un hommage
Florence stamag rég schenofen Michael
Bertrand
à la Libération alors que la plupart des
lois de Pétin sont abrogées le ministre
de la Justice de l'époque François de
Monon fait le choix de conserver cette
loi qui réprimait l'homosexualité tout
en la défendant et en la justifiant dans
son ordonnance du 8 Mai
45 outre cette disposition la
législation prohibant les relations
homosexuelles se renforcera en 1960 par
l'adoption de l'amendement de député
Paul mirget député de la Moselle qui
créera l'alinéa 2 de la l' article 330
du code pénal en effet en 1960 Paul
mirget considérait que l'homosexualité
était un fléau social qu'il convenait de
combattre il réussit à convaincre une
majorité de députés de doubler la peine
pour oututrage à la pudeur lorsqu'il
s'agissait de rapport homosexuel créant
de fait une circonstance aggravante
cette nouvelle législation répressive
entraînera une persécution
disproportionnée des personnes
homosexuelles traquées dans les lieux de
rencontre et parfois même dans dans
l'intimité de leur logie suite à une
dénonciation permettant la constitution
de fichiers d'invertis par la police
nationale et une application zellée du
droit par les juges puisque jusqu'en
1978 93 % des condamnations liées à ces
infractions se solderont à des peines
d'emprisonnement c'est en 1977 à
l'occasion du médiatique procès du
manatan accompagné de la mobilisation
d'intellectuels comme Michel foucot et
Marguerite Duras que le législateur
envisage enfin de remettre en cause ses
dispositions uniques de notre arsenal
pénal en parlant du l'affaire du manatan
qu'il me soit permis de saluer le
courage et la ténacité d'une des
victimes de cette triste affaire le
Lyonnais Michel chomara âgé de 75 ans
qui témoigne inlassablement pour lui et
pour ses compagnons d'infortune dès
1978 le Sénat ici à l'initiative de
notre regretté collègue Henry kayavé
sénateur du Lot auogaron proposa
l'abrogation de ces deux délits
d'homosexualité S souhaitant tenir
compte de l'évolution des murs et des
esprits dans la société éclairé par les
arguments du sénateur kayavé la haute
assemblée de l'époque le suivi et vota
sa proposition de loi reprise par le
député maire notre regretté collègue
Michel crpau à l'Assemblée nationale
cette proposition de loi se heurtera à
l'hostilité de la majorité des députés
il faudra attendre 1980 et l'action
volontariste de Monique Peltier
secrétaire d'État de Raymond bar pour
que ça soit abroger le caractère
aggravant l'homosexualité dans le cadre
d'un outrage à la pudeur la gauche
arrivée au pouvoir amnistia dès 1981 les
personnes condamnées pour homosexualité
enfin le 4 août 1982 à l'initiative du
ministre Robert balinter du député du
Territoire de Belfort Raymond Forni de
la rapporteur Giselle Alimi et avec le
concours de notre ancien collègue
sénateur de hotson Jean-Pierre Michel la
majorité sexuelle discriminante héritée
de Vichy sera abrogé le sociologue Régis
schlagden hoffen estime entre 50000 et
60000 personnes ont été condamnées pour
homosexuelit entre 45 et 82 en vertu de
ces deux incriminations ces travaux sont
corroborés par de nombreux
universitaires Antoine hiidier Sébastien
landriux romain Jaouen cherine bzic et
Marc bonenquy peu de ces condamnés sont
encore en vie à l'heure où je vous parle
quelques centaines au mieux pour toutes
les personnes condamnées le prix à payer
fut lourd si les fait réprimer éta
assorti d'amende ou de courtes peines de
prison ces condamnations même légères
constituaient des tâches indélébiles
pour les personnes concernés ces
sanctions pénales allaient de paire avec
le probre social
l'ostracisation le rejet des condamnés
par leur famille elles entraînaient
également bien souvent leur licenciement
ou la ruine de leur carrière
professionnelle ces pertes sociales
morales et financière ne sauraiit être
évalué ces peines infamantes ont marqué
à vie des existences elles fent voler en
éclat des vies et des familles mes chers
collègues Victor Hugo disait le plus
lourd fardeau c'est d'exister sans vivre
beaucoup de ces hommes continuèrent à
exister mais en ayant perdu le goût de
la vie ces condamnations poussèrent au
suicide certains malheureux acculé à la
mort par une presse peu scrupuleuse qui
étalé leur identité ou publier les
photos des déventures des commerces dans
lesquels ils travaillaient aucune loi ne
sera hélas en mesure de réparer ce
préjudice mais nous pouvons tâcher de
nous y employer et c'est bien l'objet de
cette proposition de loi celle-ci entend
dans son article 1 reconnaître la
responsabilité de la France dans les
répression subie il a semblé que le
rapporteur souscrivait à l'objectif de
cet article souhaitant toutefois faire
débuter la reconnaissance à 1945
estimant que la République française
n'avait pas à être tenue comptable des
agissements de régime de Vichy j'ai du
mal nous avons du mal à partager son
raisonnement juridique puisque la
République a hélas repris à son compte
et conservé la loi adoptée sous le
régime de Pétin nous avons du mal à
partager son raisonnement politique
puisque le jour de la libération de
Paris le 25 août 44 à l'Hôtel de Ville
pressé par George Bidau de proclamer la
République le Général de Gaulle avait
répondu la République n'a jamais cessé
plus récemment le 16 juillet
1995 abandonnant toutes les
circonvolutions de ses prédécesseurs à
l'Élysée et même de certains de ses
compagnons du RPR le regretté Jacques
Chirac président de la République
prononça ce discours historique
fondateur reconnaissant la
responsabilité de la France dans la
persécution des Juifs pendant
l'occupation le second article de la
proposition de loi propose de réprimer
la négation et la contestation la
déportation pour motif d'homosexualité
le troisème article propose un
dédommagement pour les victimes
condamnées je vous souhaite ici rappeler
que cette indemnisation ne concerner que
quelques centaines de personnes mes
chers collègues je forme le vœux que sur
un tel sujet l'esprit de concorde guide
vos votes il y a des lois qui ne
souffrent ni la controverse ni la
polémique j'ai le sentiment que celle-ci
en fait partie plus qu'un symbole son
adoption permettra peut-être de refermer
les PL des personnes condamnées non pas
pour ce qu'ell faisaient mais pour ce
qu'elles étaient inquiéter et condamner
quelqu'un pour son intimité pour son
identité c'est porter atteinte à sa
dignité réparer ses injustices penser
ses blessures apaiser la mémoire de ceux
qui ont pâti et qui sont morts c'est
faire preuve de notre humanité je
conclurai en citant Alphonse de la
Martine qui disait je suis de la couleur
de C le qu'on persécute alors mes chers
collègues soyons tous et toutes comme la
Martine de la couleur de ceux qu'on
persécute soyons tous et toutes comme la
Martine de la religion de ceux qu'on
opprime soyons tous et toutes comme la
Martine de l'orientation sexuelle de
ceux que la France a condamné je vous
remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est à présent à
Monsieur Francis spinner rapporteur de
la commission des lois pour 10
minutes monsieur le
Président Monsieur le président monsieur
le garde des saau mesdames Messieurs mes
chers
collègues le Sénat doit examiner une
loi qui dans son fondement ne peut que
recueillir évidemment que l'assentiment
de toute cette
assemblée mais en même temps le Sénat
est
[Musique]
de faire des lois et les lois s'appuient
sur le
droit la proposition qui vous est faite
pêche sur de nombreux
plans le premier puisque vous l'avez
abordé et je me réjouis de voir combien
Jacques Chirac est populaire surtout
depuis qu'il est mort sur les bands de
la gauche et que vous le citez à tout
moment la question de la
période je vous fais observer
d'abord que même ceux qui ont travaillé
distinguent la période de 42 45 de la
période
4582 et d'ailleurs vous-même dans votre
proposition de loi vous le faites
puisque lors que vous parlez du lit de
négationnisme évidemment vous ne faites
pas courir le délit de négationnisme
pour les faits de 45 à 82 et donc à la
fois pour une question de morale
politique je vois mal comment la
République pourrait endosser la
responsabilité des crimes de Vich la
période 42 45 est une période qui
au-delà du cadre législatif est une
période effectivement de répression
politique de l'homosexualité d'une
manière idéologique et organisée et
voilà pourquoi j'ai fait cette
séparation et que la commission des lois
a décidé d'adopter dans l'article 1er le
fait que les choses partent depuis
1945 le deè aspect de votre loi c'est la
tion
financière là aussi vous avez cité et
c'est vrai et l'audition d'Arian chemin
était très inclérente de ce point de vue
tous les drames qui sont nés de cette
loi mais comme vous l'avez dit ce n'est
pas tellement l'application de la loi
mais le regard de la société qui a causé
ce dommage ce n'est pas parce que le
juge a condamné c'est parce que la
société française dans toute sa
composante était à l'époque
homophobe je me souviens que la moitié
des psychiatres venait vous expliquer il
y a 50 ans que l'homosexualité é été
inscrite par les maladies mentales je me
souviens pardonnez-moi c'est le
privilège de l'âge une émission qui
s'appelait les Dossiers de l'écran où on
disait ce soir nous allons parler d'une
maladie mentale l'homosexualité donc le
regard qu'a posé la société on peut par
anachronisme dire c'était très mal il y
a 50 ans mais ce ce n'est pas la loi qui
en a été la première responsable de ce
préjudice réel parce que le nombre de
drames de gens qui ont été exclus qui
ont dû changer de métier qui ont dû
changer de
ville ces drames ont été effectivement
affreux et ont causé des suicides et un
certain nombre de drames mais ça n'est
pas la faute je suis désolé de le dire
de la République c'est une
responsabilité collective de toute la
société et le Sénat n'a pas pour rôle de
venir juger la était avec ses préjugés
50 ans après nous allons nous en tenir
au droit or sur le plan du droit il est
indiscutable que cette loi était
discriminatoire pour que tout le monde
comprenne ce qui était toléré entre
personnes
hétérosexuelle devenait un délit à
partir du moment il y avait lieu entre
personnes homosexuelles la même
situation ne produisant pas la même les
mêmes effets juridiques c'est le la
discrimination indiscutable et de de
cette discrimination là oui la
République a commis une faute et cette
faute est indiscutable et patente sur la
réparation toujours je vous ferai
observer que à partir du moment où nous
sommes sur le délit de
82 les articles que vous avez visés ces
articles qui sont des articles de
matière délictuelle des condamnations
prononcé pour des délits la loi
d'amnestie a effacé sur le plan pénal
l'existence même de ces condamnations et
il y a des règles de prescription et que
vous ne pouvez pas 40 ans après sauf à
créer un dangereux précédent venir dire
que la prescription n'existe pas et que
donc il peut y avoir matière à
réparation mais madame de La Conte vous
êtes une très brillante juriste tout le
monde le sait vous démontrerez le
contraire je n'en doute pas mais si vous
arrivez à me citer des exemples de
prescription plus de quarantenir si vous
faites allusion à la loi mémorielle sur
les archis ça n'a strictement rien à
voir relisez la loi et vous verrez que
ce qui est réparation ce sont les
conditions indignes et l'effet d'une
politique qui est assumée par l'État ça
n'a rien à voir avec le sujet qui nous
préoccupe voilà pourquoi nous avons
estimé la commission des lois estimé
qu'il fallait effectivement ne pas
retenir le principe des réparations
trème point c'est le problème du
négationnisme deux raisons pour
lesquelles la Commission ne peut pas
vous suivre première c'est une
conception philosophique des droits de
l'homme les droits de l'homme sont
indivisibles les droits de l'homme sont
universels et à partir de ce moment-là
nous considérons que la loi le procès de
nurberg a montré que la déportation la
négation de la déportation dans son
ensemble que cela concerne les Juifs les
communistes les résistants les tiganes
les homosexuels constituait le crime
contre l'humanité et que donc la
négation de ce fait entre dans le cadre
de la loi qui est consacré par l'article
24 de la loi de 81 sur la presse et
qu'il n'y a donc pas la nécessité de
créer une infraction nouvelle qui n'est
ni légitime sur le plan de
l'indivisibilité et l'universalité des
droits de l'homme et sur le plan
juridique compenu ce que prévoit déjà le
statut de nurberg j'ajouterai d'ailleurs
que ce qui va plutôt dans le sens de
cette position c'est qu'un certain
nombre d'associations luttant contre
l'homophobie ont engagé des procédures
sur le fondement de la loi de 81 et que
évidemment si on vous suivait ce serait
la preuve que ça ne rentre pas dans le
cadre de la loi de 81 et ce serait la
relaxe que ces associations poursuivent
il s'agit pas de faire plaisir à ces
associations il s'agit tout simplement
d'examiner le droit et donc voilà
pourquoi nous avons été partisans de
faire un article unique qui a été soumis
et qui reconnaît effectivement que la
République a pratiqué une politique
discriminatoire de 45 à
82 nous sommes dans le symbole et le
symbole est important il est important
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui encore
des gamins de 18 ans sont chassés de
chez eux lorsque leurs parents
découvrent leur homosexualité et il est
important que le Sénat affirme que les
lois discriminatoires contre les
homosexuels sont des lois qui sont
contraires à l'idé
de ce que nous avons de la République de
la fraternité et de la condition humaine
sur ce plan-l nous sommes d'accord mais
le Sénat ne peut pas faire plus c'est un
travail d'éducation de toute la société
c'est un travail de chacun c'est un
travail dans les famille c'est un
travail dans l'éducation ce n'est pas la
loi malheureusement qui va régler tous
les problèmes de l'homophobie mais en en
approuvant
symboliquement que la République en
créant une discrimination c'est mal
conduit je pense que c'est une aide qui
est apportée à ceux qui mènent ce combat
qui est un combat légitime voilà
pourquoi j'aurais souhaité un consensus
dernier point que je voudrais aborder et
je suis sûr monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur l'auteur de la proposition de
loi que vous aurez l'honnêteté
intellectuelle de dire que c'est vrai
nous n'avons pas refusé et j'étis très
choqué de le lire un certain nombre
d'auditions nous avons dû agir dans un
temps très court qui n'est pas du fait
ni de la mission ni du rapporteur ce que
nous n'avons pas pu entendre nous leur
avons demandé des contributions écrites
et ils nous les ont fournis et dire que
nous avons refusé ou que nous avons
baclé le sujet est assez scandaleux et
je suis sûr que vous aurez raison de
rectifier tout cela mais ces critiques
sont intéressantes parce qu'elles
montrent qu'en réalité vous englobez un
problème qui couvre des périodes
différentes des situations différentes
et que je pense que le travail reste
affaire et que il serait souhaitable
effectivement que l'autorité publique
prenne un certain nombre de décisions
pour missionner des universitaire les
encourager les aider dans leurs travaux
pour avoir une réalité de ce qui s'est
passé car lorsque nous avons interrogé
la direction des affaires criminelles et
des grâces nous avons été dans
l'impossibilité et d'une certaine
manière c'est heureux ça prouve qu'il y
a pas de fichier à la Chancellerie des
gens condamnés pour homosexualité ce qui
est plutôt heureux mais nous avons
beaucoup de travail à faire et le
chercheur qui est le plus actif en la
matière reconnaît toute la difficulté de
sa tâche pour regarder PV par PV donc je
pense que nous pouvons arriver à une
bonne loi de consensus qui réaffirme un
principe oui la République a fauté mais
vous ne pouvez pas aller au-delà je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est à présent à monsieur Éric DUP pont
moréti gardau ministre de la
Justice
Bir monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président de la commission des lois
monsieur le sénateur Bourgi monsieur le
rapporteur spiner mesdames et messieurs
les
sénateurs nous nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la niche
socialiste pour débattre d'un sujet de
grande
importance et sans aucun doute trop
longtemps oublié et je veux le dire
d'emblé monsieur le
sénateur votre proposition de loi a
indubitablement beaucoup de sens et je
veux d'ailleurs vous en remercier
chaleureusement en vous écoutant tout à
l'heure je me disais mais on a vraiment
du mal à imaginer
aujourd'hui même si tout n'est pas
parfait à quel point les homosexuels ont
été
maltraités mal mené
mépriser c'est simple aujourd'hui au
fond nous sommes réunis pour dire que la
République n'est jamais aussi
grande que lorsqu'elle sait reconnaître
ses erreurs et ici c'est fautes car oui
votre texte monsieur le sénateur Bourgie
a pour objet la reconnaissance par la
République française de la politique de
discrimination mise en œuvre pendant
près de 40 ans à l'encontre des
personnes homosexuelles et condamné à
raison de leur orientation sexuelle
réelle ou
présumée si cette politique passée de
discrimination fait aujourd'hui honte à
notre République je tiens toutefois à
rappeler qu'il n'en a pas toujours été
ainsi alors que les relations
homosexuelles étaient incriminées durant
l'Ancien Régime elles ont été
décriminalisées en 1791 au lendemain de
la révolution de sorte que pendant plus
d'un siècle et demi aucune incrimination
de l'homosexualité n'était en vigueur
dans notre pays ce faisant notre pays
était fort de cette législation l'un des
plus progressistes mais tout cela a été
balayé avec l'instauration du régime de
Vichy car c'est bien Vichy qui aura
raison de cet acquis puisque la loi du 6
août
1942 modifiant l'article 334 du code
pénal punira d'un emprisonnement de 6
mois à 3 ans quiconque aura commis un ou
plusieurs actes impudique ou contre
nature avec un mineur de son sexe âgé de
moins de 21
ans comme vous le rappelez monsieur le
sénateur Bourgis ces évolutions
législatives ont bouleversé et par
parfois détruit la vie des homosexuels
de l'époque en donnant une base légale à
ce qui fut une véritable
répression non pas de ce qu'ell
faisaient mais de ce qu'elles
étaient cela bien sûr nous ne
l'acceptons plus et aujourd'hui non
seulement nous le reconnaissons mais d'
nous le dénonçons et nous pouvons le
dénoncer grâce à votre loi au fond vous
substiuez à une loi de haine une loi
d'unité de reconnaissance et de mémoire
j'y suis favorable il m'est impossible
de ne pas rappeler qu'il fallut pour
mettre un terme à cette répression
pénale attendre Robert Badinter sa
majorité socialiste d'Alor et la loi du
4 août
1982 enfin devrais-je dire pour voir
cette disposition abrogé et mettre ainsi
un terme à 40 années de pénalisation de
l'homosexualité
quand on vous parle de bas d'interre
tout le monde pense à l'abollition de la
peine de mort qui est en soit déjà une
œuvre presque complète pour un garde des
saau un de mes très anciens
prédécesseurs m'avait confessé après ma
prise de fonction la difficulté qui fut
la sienne de passer au ministère de la
justice après l'illustre badinterre et
il ajouté mi résigné mi
philosophe que voulez-vous éc on abolit
la peine de mort une seule fois
heureusement pour lui il avait oublié
cette autre œuvre majeure que fut la
dépénalisation de
l'homosexualité 40 ans plus tard il est
plus que temps de reconnaître sur le
plan mémoriel que les condamnations
prononcé l'ont été sur le fondement de
lois erronées en effet comme vous le
savez chaque condamnation ou mise en
cause portant sur une infraction liée à
l'homosexualité a eu des conséquences
ale lourde et parfois et souvent
dévastatrice pour la personne qui en a
fait l'objet jusqu'au bannissement de la
F de la sphère familiale ou
professionnelle si mon ministère ne
dispose pas de chiffres quant au nombre
de ces
condamnations et on en est tous très
heureux s'agissant d'infraction
aujourd'hui à Broger divers travaux de
recherche mené sur le sujet estime que
plus de 10000 personnes ont été
condamnées entre 1945 et
1982 avec pour plus de 90 % d'entre
elles une condamnation à une peine
d'emprisonnement ferme ces chiffres
évidemment nous interpellent et nous
obligent à œuvrer ensemble à reconnaître
clairement et sans aucune ambigué la
mise en œuvre de cette législation
déshonorante la proposition de loi qui
vous est aujourd'hui présentée poursuit
cet objectif et doit à ce titre retenir
toute notre attention et je le dis toute
notre bienveillance allons maintenant
dans les détails de ces
disposition l'article 1er de cette
proposition prévoit ainsi de reconnaître
la responsabilité de la République
Française pour la politique de
discrimination mise en œuvre à
l'encontre des homosexuels ou présumer
tel et condamné sur la base
d'infraacction aujourd'hui abrogé j'y
suis favorable sur le principe et je
sais que le rapporteur spiner
apportera par amendement certaines
précisions
intéressantes cette écriture de
compromis aura surtout l'avantage de
permettre sous toute réserve bien sûr
l'adoption par le Sénat d'un texte
important pour l'apaisement de notre
société je crois que dans le contexte
actuel il serait vraiment dommage de
s'en priver l'article 2 créer un nouvel
article dans la loi du 29 juillet
1881 sur la liberté de la presse afin de
réprimer le fait de contester nier
minorer ou banaliser l'existence de
déportation de personnes en raison de
leur homosexualité depuis la France et
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale je
tiens à rappeler devant vous qu'il ne
fait aucun doute j'insiste aucun doute
que des personnes homosexuelles ont bien
été déportées pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et qu'il s'agit là de crime
évidemment atrocce toutefois toutefois
j'ai met une réserve quant à la
constitutionnalité de cette nouvelle
infraction en effet le Conseil
constitutionnel a déjà jugé que le
législateur ne pouvait créer
d'incrimination réprimant pénalement la
contestation d'une vérité historique
lorsqu'elle était établi par la loi en
raison de l'atteinte portée à la liberté
d'expression une reconnaissance
judiciaire préalable est nécessaire ce
qui n'est en l'état pas le cas l'article
3 ouvre au bénéfice des personnes
condamnées en application des
infractions visées à l'article 1er une
allocation forfaire de 10000 € ainsi
qu'une allocation variable en fonction
du nombre de jours de privation de
liberté fixé à 150 € par jour elle
prévoit également le remboursement du
montant de l'amende dont les personnes
reconnues coupables se sont acquitté en
application de leur condamnation
toutefois il s'agit là d'une mesure
d'indemnisation nécessitant bien sûr
d'apporter la preuve d'une condamnation
ancienne difficile à rapporter tant dans
son principe le jugement que dans sa
mise à exécution à savoir l'application
de la peine en question sa mise en
pratique app est donc extrêmement
extrêmement complexe l'article 4 et je
termine institue auprès de la première
ministre une commission nationale
indépendante de
reconnaissance de réparation des
préjudices subis par les personnes
condamnées chargé de statuer sur les
demandes d'indemnisation présenté ces
dispositions semblent relever plutôt du
domaine réglementaire et poser là encore
des difficultés probatoires lié bien sûr
à l'ancienneté des faits pouvant donner
lieu à indemnisation vous l'aurez
compris au regard des différentes
réserves énoncées précédemment sur les
articles 2 3 et 4 le gouvernement s'en
remettra à la sagesse du Sénat mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs le Gouvernement
est favorable au principe de cette
proposition de loi qui viendra
reconnaître la mise en œuvre pendant 40
ans d'une politique de discrimination et
de répression pénale qui n'aurait jamais
dû exister s'il est toujours complexe de
regarder les lois d'hier avec les
lunettes d'aujourd'hui il en va ici des
principes fondamentaux non négociables
de notre République celui de la liberté
celui de l'égalité et bien sûr et bien
sûr celui de la fraternité c'est
pourquoi il est impératif de reconnaître
les aements du passé mais aussi leur
terribles conséquences pour
plusieurs générations de nos compatriote
reconnaître une erreur ça n'est à
l'évidence pas un une marque de
faiblesse loin de là c'est dire que nos
principes fondamentaux valent plus que
notre orgueil car l'orgueil d'être
français c'est aussi d'en assumer toute
notre
histoire toute l'histoire de notre pays
et dire lorsque l'on a fait fausse route
pour montrer aux générations futures que
notre République est les principes
universels qui la sout attend mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs triomphe
toujours merci monsieur le ministre dans
la suite de la discussion générale la
parole est au président Alain Marc pour
le groupe les indépendants pour 4
minutes chers
collègues monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues en
abrogeant le 2e alinéa de l'article 331
du code pénal la loi du 4 août 1982 a
participé à la dépénalisation de
l'homosexualité cette loi a fêté l'an
dernier ces 40 ans et c'est dans ce
contexte de commémoration que notre
collègue Hussein Bourgi a pris
l'initiative heureuse de déposer la
proposition de loi portant réparation
des personnes condamnées pour
homosexualité entre 1942 et
1982 si l'on doit beaucoup à la loi du 4
août 1982 il ne faut pas oublier que la
France fut dès
1791 le premier pays au monde à avoir
décriminalisé les relations
homosexuelles en effet sous l'Ancien
Régime l'homosexualité constituait un
crime puni de mort et de nombreux
homosexuels ont été brûlés vif à
Paris aujourd'hui nul ne saurait
contester la triste réalité de la
discrimination instaurée par la loi
pénale sur le fondement de l'orientation
sexuelle de 1942 à 1982 c'est-à-dire
sous le régime de Vichi nous ne pouvons
que regretter qu'au cours de ces quatre
décennies le code pénal français est
contenu des dispositions visant certains
actes homosexuels qui conduisirent à des
condamnations par les juridiction
française maintenir de telles
discriminations dans notre société était
indigne de de la France c'est pourquoi
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
cet après-midi poursuit un objectif bien
légitime je passerai sur les articles de
1 à 7 à 5 compte tenu du temps qui m'est
imparti 4 minutes du fait de son
ambition cette proposition de loi
présente un intérêt majeur monsieur le
ministre l'a dit d'un point de vue
symbolique comme d'autres pays l'ont
fait il est fondamental que la France
reconnaisse officiellement la répression
judiciaire dont ont été victimes les
personnes
homosexuelles toutefois il nous faut
constater que ce texte se heurte à
plusieurs obstacles et vous l'avez dit
aussi monsieur le rapporteur d'une part
la réparation financière entraînerait un
contournement de la prescription c'est
ce que vous avez aussi noté d'autre part
la création d'un délit de contestation
négation et banalisation ou minoration
ou transancière de la déportation des
personnes homosexuelles depuis la France
durant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
apparaît superflu même si le terme n'est
peut-être pas très très bien choisi dans
la mesure où cette infraction est déjà
couverte par le droit en vigueur enfin
la période retenue par la proposition de
loi de 1942 à
1982 ne me semble pas pertinente dans la
mesure où la République aujourd'hui n'a
pas à assumer les crimes du régime de
Vichy monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues une réparation symbolique me
paraît indiscutable
elle permettrait d'affirmer la faute de
la République et de reconnaître sa
responsabilité c'est aussi l'honneur de
celle-ci que de la reconnaître disait à
l'instant monsieur le ministre très
sensible à l'objectif poursuivi par ce
texte mais estimant indispensable de
Pier plusieurs difficultés juridiques le
vote de notre groupe Les Indépendants
dépendra des modifications qui seront
apportées merci si la parole est à
présent à notre collègue Jean-Michel
Arnaud pour le groupe Union centriste
pour 6
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers
collègues les hommes naissent et
demeurent libres et égau en droit les
distinctions sociales ne peuvent être
fondées que sur l'utilité commune vous
avez toutes et tous reconnu l'article
1er de la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen du 26 août 1789 à
lui seul cet article pte en son sein les
idéaux universalistes de la Révolution
française imprégné de l'héritage des
lumières la période révolutionnaire fit
de la France un refuge pour tous les
combattants de la liberté c'est par
cette aspiration a éclairer les peuples
du monde que nos aïux ont posé les bases
juridiqu de l'État moderne et
progressiste et acté des avancées
sociales
inédites divorce par consentement mutuel
en
1793 première abolition de l'esclavage
en 1794 et bien sûr la première
dépénalisation de l'homosexualité en
1791 plus précisément et les mots ont
l'importance la dépénalisation du crime
de sodomie qui était puni précédemment
par le feu premier pays au monde à
légiféré en ce sens la France
réintroduira la répression pénale de
l'homosexualité par la loi du 6 août
1942 l'abject gouvernement de Pétin et
sa révolution nationale pénalisa
clairement en étant homophobe pénalisa
les relations entre personnes de même
sexe dès lors que l'une d'entre elles
avait entre 13 et 21 ans la Libération
le rétablissement de l'ordre républicain
ne modifiera qu'à la marche cette
infraction discriminatoire qui restera
malheureusement en vigueur jusqu'en 1982
à celle-ci s'ajouter une seconde
infraction prévue à l'article 330 du
code pénal qui réprimait tout outrage
public à la pudeur consistant à je cite
un acte contre nature avec un individu
de même sexe je pense que le choix l'
aussi des mots en diselons sur une
époque que nous espérons aujourd'hui
toutes et tous révolu durant qure
décennies nous avons eu affaire à une
discrimination pénalement acceptée dès
1978 notre haute assemblée et c'est
important de le rappeler avait adopté
une mesure visant à abroger le délit
d'homosexualité mesure autre temps qui
avait fait l'objet d'un désaccord avec
l'Assemblée nationale là aussi un autre
temps il a fallu attendre la loi du 4
août 1982 pour que l'homosexualité soit
officiellement dépénalisée en France je
rappelle et c'est là aussi nécessaire de
le rappeler que sur les 197 pays que
compte le globe 69 états encore
aujourd'hui considèrent l'homosexualité
comme illégale et lorsqu'on analyse des
polltions politiques par exemple du
nouveau président argentin ravier may en
matière sociale mais aussi en matière de
société on se dit que rien n'est
définitivement acquis à l'occasion du
40e anniversaire de l'adoption de cette
loi notre collègue saint Bourgie et nos
collègues du groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains ont inscrit
à l'ordre du jour l'examen de la
proposition de loi portant réparation
des des personnes condamné pour
homosexualité entre 1942 et
1982 je salue ici amicalement et
fraternellement s'il me le permet
l'engagement d' Husain Borgi qui honore
par ses engagements récurrents en la
matière notre Haute Assemblée si la
commission des lois ne l'a pas adopté il
me semble c'est pour mieux la réécrire
et nous verrons les amendements qui nous
seront proposés dans quelques minutes en
ce sens je remercie également le
rapporteur Francis piner pour son
analyse et également d'engagement qui
est le sien en matière d'analyse
juridique et son raisonnement qui nous a
toutes et tous interpellé permet-i
permettez-moi de m'attarder maintenant
sur les trois principaux articles de
cette proposition de loi l'article 1er
vise à reconnaître C a été rappelé la
responsabilité de la République
française du fait d'infraction
pénalisant
l'homosexualité bien qu'il faille
recentrer l'article sur la période
allant de 1945 à
1982 et simplifier la description du
motif de responsabilité notre groupe
l'Union centriste soutient avec force
cette mesure pour reprendre les mots du
rapporteur le législateur s'est fourvoyé
en opérant une discrimination sur le
fondement de l'orientation sexuelle il
s'agit d'un fait indiscutable qui je
n'en doute pas fait l'unanimité dans cet
hémicycle en aucun cas notre République
ne peut réprimer un individu pour ce
qu'il est en démocratie et dans notre
République tout citoyen répond de ses
actes et non de son identité de sa
religion ou de son orientation sexuel
ainsi durant quatre décennies la France
a laissé sufficiter ce que le garde des
saau Robert Badinter qualifiait de
pesanteur d'une époque odieuse de notre
histoire l'article 2 propose de créer un
délit réprimant la contestation ou la la
minoration ou transère de la déportation
des personnes homosexuelle durant la
période de la Seconde Guerre mondiale si
l'intention est louable l'article 24 B
de la loi du 29 juillet 1881 couvre déjà
la déportation des homosexuels ainsi
comme le souigne le rapporteur
l'autonomisation de ce délit viendrait
perturber les tenstion en cours je
rappelle qu'en l'état actuel du droit un
individu qui s'exprimerait qui
exprimerait publiquement toute
contestation de l'existence de CRIM
contre l'humanité où toute négation
minoration banalisation de ces derniers
encourt une peine maximale d'un an de
prison et de 45000 € d'amende et la
déportation des homosexuels en tant que
tel entre clairement dans ce dispositif
enfin l'article 3 fixe les modalités de
réparation financière des personnes
condamnées pour homosexualité je crois
que l'essentiel a été dit par le
rapporteur je ne détaillerai pas pas
plus en avant nous devons dén avant
collectivement tirer les enseignements
du passé pour les transmettre aux
générations futures la loi permet de se
confronté à ses responsabilités passées
mais c'est bien l'éducation et la
transmission qui évite à une nation
d'oublier son histoire cette mission
nous incombe au quotidien à titre
personnel je me souviens d'avoir reçu en
tant que invité d'honneur l'association
SOS Homophobie lors du congrès de mes de
mes élus des Hautes Alpes en 2022 j'en
profite pour saluer les multiples
actions menées par les
associations pour lutter contre
l'homophobie et contre toute forme
d'exclusion soutenons-les apiser la
mémoire de ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
morts est indispensable comme vous
l'aurez compris le groupe Union
centriste votera en faveur de la version
j'espère réécrite et qui fera consensus
de cette proposition de loi en un
article unique car il est important que
le Sénat affirme ici que l'homophobie
dans cette république et dans ce pays
est inacceptable et que la République ne
s'est pas bien comporté envers certains
de nos concitoyens au vu de l'
orientation sexuelle je vous remercie
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est à présent à Madame Mélanie Vogel
pour le groupe écologie solidarité et
territoire pour 4
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je
voudrais d'abord remercier Husain
Bourgie et l'ensemble du groupe
socialiste pour nous donner l'occasion
dans un moment où la France si souvent
recule sur ses grands principes de la
faire grandir il y a dans l'histoire des
nations comme dans l'histoire des vies
des femmes et des hommes que nous sommes
des horreurs que le passé ne peut jamais
contenir elles débordent sur notre
présent elles assombrissent notre avenir
parce que leurs souvenirs blessent nos
mémoires mais aussi et peut-être surtout
parce qu'il détruit une certaine image
de nous-même de la société et du pays
que nous voudrions être parce que entre
ce que nous disons être le grand pays
des Droits humains et des lumières et ce
que nous avons fait il y a parfois un
gouffre dans lequel nous avons très peur
de sombrer or reconnaître et réparer ses
faute même et surtout les pires et
l'unique promesse crédible que nous
pouvons faire aux victimes mais aussi à
nous-mêmes que nous ne voulons plus
jamais ça c'est pourquoi c'est le lot
des grandes nations celles qui veulent
progresser celles qui veulent devenir
meilleur que de cesser de nier les
horreurs qu'elles ont produites et
d'accepter de porter la pleine
responsabilité de leurs fautes d'aller
un peu la souffrance de celles et ceux
qui en ont payé le prix en cessant d'y
ajouter le poids du dénis et du mépris
et en s'accordant sur le fait que jamais
cela n'aurait dû arriver c'est pourquoi
la France a déjà voté un certain nombre
de lois mémorielles mais la France a
jusqu'ici eu la mémoire sélective
certaines personnes n'ont jamais jusqu'à
présent pu bénéficier d'une
reconnaissance officielle des violences
des discriminations et des condamnations
subies il est donc plus que temps la loi
de 42 que la France a choisi de faire
sienne à la Libération que la France a
repris à son compte reconnaissant de
fait une continuité juridique en la
matière avec le régime de Vichy a établi
des crimes sans victime les homosexuels
étaient coupable d'être ils ont été
persécutés emprisonnés fichés intimidés
menacés blessés tués parce qu'ils exist
les lesbiennes elles n'étaient
généralement pas considéré comme coupabl
d'exister puisqu'ell n'était pas
considéré comme existant tout court
d'ailleurs toute l'histoire des
violences contre la communauté LGBT les
lesbiennes ont été moins condamnés
pénalement que les autres non pas parce
qu'on les respectait davantage mais
parce qu'on ne les respectait même pas
assez pour voir qu'elles étaient là bref
c'est le minimum pour une société dont
la devise est liberté égalité fraternité
que de reconnaître sa responsabilité
dans les persécutions subies par les
personnes LGBT entre 1942 et
1982 c'est aussi le minimum h que de
réparer la faute reconnue car
reconnaître sans réparer c'est
reconnaître qu'à moitié mais je voulais
aussi dire autre chose on a tous dit
depuis tout à l'heure à quel point le
régime discriminatoire entre 42 et 82
était horrible mais il a fallu attendre
2010 pour que le transsexualisme comme
c'était écrit soit retiré de la liste
des affections psychiatriques 2013 pour
que le régime du mariage en France cesse
d'être homophobe 2018 pour que les
personnes décédées ayant le VIH sida
puisse à nouveau bénéficier de soins
funéraires 2021 pour que l'accès à la
PMA cesse d'être lesbophobe nous
attendons toujours qu'elle cesse d'être
transphobe l'État a forcé les personnes
trans jusqu'en 2016 à subir des
célérisations forcées en France pour
pouvoir être reconnu pour qui elles
étaient aujourd'hui encore une personne
trans adulte en pleine possession de ses
moyens ne peut pas décider légalement
qu'elle est qui elle est c'est un juge
qui doit accepter de le faire pendant
que les personnes si genre elle qui
n'ont d'ailleurs jamais rien eu à dire
sauvant leur identité de genre reconnu
depuis toujours la France a été
condamnée trois fois par les Nations
unies pour traitement et mutilation
subie par les personnes intersexes
souvent dès la naissance alors il y aura
peut-être dans 40 ans une loi qui
demandera pardon aux personnes
transstérilisé à celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas pu tenir et qui se sont
suicidés aux personnes intersexe mutilé
mais il y a une chose que nous pouvons
faire dès maintenant pour avoir moins
regretter demain c'est faire maintenant
l'égalité réelle et totale pour toutes
les personnes LGBT je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à notre collègue Yann brossa
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologiste kanaki pour 4
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le garde des saau monsieur le président
de la commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur un vieux penseur barbu disait
que celui qui ne connaît pas l'histoire
est condamné à la revivre au fond cette
proposition de loi nous permet de
revenir sur certaines pages de de notre
histoire et et de les regarder en face
au fond de quoi parlons-nous Husain
Bourgi l'a dit tout à l'heure nous
parlons d'hommes qui par milliers en
France ont été réprimés en raison de
leur orientation sexuelle nous parlons
de 40 ans de répression pénale de
l'homosexualité bien sûr 1942 cette loi
établie par le régime de Vichy qui
prévoit de poursuivre les hommes qui
sont coupables d'avoir des relations
sexuelle avec des hommes c'est aussi
1960 Husain Bourgi l'a dit tout à
l'heure cet amendement du député Paul
mirget qui classe l'homosexualité comme
un fléau social et qui prévoit que le
fait de montrer des signes d'affection
entre adultes consentant du même sexe
suffit pour être puni
d'emprisonnement au-delà des milliers de
condamnés avec ces deux lois il faut
ajouter ceux innombrables qui ont connu
les effets de la répression et les
raides sur les lieu de rencontre il a
donc fallu attendre
1982 et la loi fornie pour mettre un
terme à la répression pénale pour
homosexualité en France et je voudrais
aussi citer Jack rallit ministre de la
Santé qui en
1982 retire l'homosexualité de la liste
des maladies mentales toute une
génération donc qui a vécu avec cette
épée de de damoclesès au-dessus de la
tête qui a vécu dans la peur qui a vécu
dans la menace toutes ces vies qui ont
été étaé brisé l'prre sociale pour
certains le licenciement pour d'autres
parfois les mêmes la rupture familiale
l'homosexualité à l'époque se vivait
dans la honte et tout cela au fond pose
deux questions la première c'est comment
il se fait que cette discrimination
cette discrimination dans la loi a pu
durer aussi longtemps si elle a pu durer
pendant 40 ans jusqu'en 1982 ça n'est
pas si lointain c'est parce que cette
homophobie dans la loi avait ses
soutiens c'est parce qu'il se trouvait
des responsables politiques des
ministres des parlementaires pour
défendre cette homophobie ça n'est pas
simplement la faute à la société c'est
un peu facile de rejeter la faute sur la
société il y avait des responsables
politiques qui militaient pour cette
homophobie d'État et ça n'est pas faire
in jure à notre Haute Assemblée que de
rappeler que en
1982 le Sénat vote contre la
dépénalisation
de l'homosexualité contre et je me suis
replongé dans les arguments du
rapporteur Étienne da qui à l'époque
pour justifier son vote et celui de la
majorité sénatoriale indique que
l'homosexualité est un dérèglement
physiologique et que les homosexuels
sont des enfants égarés et la deuxième
question qui se pose c'est pourquoi
l'homosexualité a persisté et a survécu
à la dépénalisation pourquoi est-ce
qu'encore aujourd'hui des homes des
femmes sont victimes d'homophobie parce
que là encore là encore à tous les
niveaux de la société y compris au plus
haut niveau de la société il y a des
propos homophobes qui sont tenus tous
les jours et vous savez j'ai en tête ce
sera ce que je dirais pour finir un
échange à l'Assemblée nationale au
moment du débat du Pax entre Christine
Boutin et une député communiste muget
Jacquin et à l'époque Christine Boutin
fait mine de pleurer sur les souffrances
des des homosexuel et muget Jacquin
député de sa saint-en lui répond quand
ils vous entendent je comprends qu'ils
souffr et tout cela résume bien le fait
que ça n'est pas l'homosexualité qui
engendre de la souffrance c'est
l'homophobie et tout ce qui nous permet
de lutter contre l'homophobie et ce
texte nous le permet et bon apprendre à
la fois pour ceux d'hier et pour ceux
d'aujourd'hui qui sont
confrontés merci chers collègues la
parole est à présent à notre collègue
Nathalie de lâre pour le groupe r DSE
pour 4
minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des saau monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues il y a des filations
dont le législateur se passerait bien
celle par exemple de disposition pénales
relative à la majorité sexuelle
discriminatoire entre hétérosexuel et
homosexuel qui furent introduites sous
le régime de Vichi et maintenu
par les deux républiques suivantes
pendant presque 40 ans je ne reviendrai
pas sur l'historique de ce dispositif
très bien rappelé par les orateurs
précédent je souhaite en toute
simplicité saluer l'initiative de notre
collègue Husain Bourgi ainsi que le
travail de notre rapporteur Francis
spiner qui a pu nous apporter un certain
nombre d'éclaircissements tant en
commission qu'ici en séance publique
vous nous proposer chers collègues trois
dispositifs le premier est déclaratif à
travers la reconnaissance et le de la
politique de criminalisation et de
discrimination mise en œuvre entre le 6
août 1942 et le 4 août
1982 à l'encontre des personnes
homosexuelles ou
présumer-elles certains peuvent douter
de la pertinence de ces articles
déclarative qui semble dépourvu de réell
porté normative d'autant que pour ces
faits le Parlement a adopté une noie
d'amnistie le 4 août
1981 seulement ce geste bien
qu'essentiel n'a signifié que
l'effacement des des condamnations sans
pour autant entraîner une réparation
morale des mots causés par de telles
condamnations qui sont allés pour
certains jusqu'au suicide avec ce
nouveau dispositif notre nation
assumerait regretterait et demanderait
aussi pardon pour ces discrimination
passée en revanche je suis réservée sur
le deuxième point quant à la création
d'un délit pénal venant spécifiquement
réprimer les propos visant à nier la
déportation Surie par les personnes
homosexuelles au cours de la seconde
guerre mondial opéré depuis la France en
effet le tribunal de Nuremberg a livré
une définition du crime contre
l'humanité assassinat extermination
réduction en esclavage déportation et
tout autre acte inhumain commis contre
toute population civile avant ou pendant
la guerre aussi dans la continuité de
Nuremberg le négationnisme doit
êtreamné sévèrement mais dans sa
globalité et sans distinction sans qu'il
soit nécessaire de spécifier un à un les
motifs de la déportation Juifs
handicapés zigan homosexuel opposants
politiqu cette liste n'est
malheureusement pas exhaustive mais la
condamnation est opérationnelle
juridiquement enfin il nous est proposé
en 3oème point un dispositif
indemnitaire afin de prévoir une
réparation financière vis-à-vis des
personnes condamnées pour homosexualité
entre 42 et 82 j'y suis plutôt favorable
car lorsqu'un dommage est subi il doit
donner lieu à réparation plusieurs états
ont déjà procédé à cette réparation
pourquoi ne pas inscrire la France dans
cette dynamique d'autant qu'il s'agit
plus d'un geste symbolique cononéreux la
question de l'homophobie et des
discriminations liées à l'orientation
sexuelle Contin continuent d'être
préoccupante dans notre pays il faut
l'avir dans un contexte global celui
d'une société où certains se referment
d'une société qui voit ressurgir des
doctrines occultes et
obscurantiste le rapport de
l'association SOS Homophobie est sans
ambigué le ress ement des actes
homophobes révèle une augmentation des
agressions physiques ce constat est
alarmant il est le reflet d'un certain
échec de notre politique sociale et
éducative l'homophobie n'est pas une
posture ce n'est pas une opinion mais
c'est un délit à condamner fermement
nous voterons donc malgré quelques
réserves pour cette proposition de loi
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent à Madame NAD
pour le groupe RDP pour 5
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le garde des saau monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues le 4 août 1982 la
loi du député Raymond Forni soutenue par
Robert badinterre venait abroger le
délit d'homosexualité né 40 ans plus tôt
sous le régime de Vichy notre garde
d'essau avait juste déclaré devant les
députés il n'est que temps de prendre
conscience de tout ce que la France doit
aux homosexuels la rapporteur du texte
Giselle Alimi en introduction des au
débat rappelait quant à elle ceci s'il
est un choix individuel par essence et
devant échapper à toute codification
c'est bien celui de la sexualité il ne
peut pas y avoir de morale sexuelle de
tous qui s'impose à la morale sexuel de
chacun nous ne sauons maintenir dans
notre droit un texte discriminatoire qui
met connaî une réalité sociale humaine
importante et qui ne peut trouver dans
la société actuelle aucune
justification pendant 40 ans en effet
certaines relations homosexuelles ont
donc été condamnées amende peine
d'emprisonnement outre la dépénalisation
et la fin du délit d'outrage le texte de
82 a mis un terme à la discrimination
qui existait en terme de majorité
sexuelle entre les personnes
hétérosexuelles et homosexuelles les
relations entre hommes étaient en effet
interdites jusqu'à 21 ans an 15 ans pour
les personnes hétérosexuelles la fin
d'une injustice et ce fut un soulagement
après des décennies de stigmatisation où
la sanction judiciaire se doublait
souvent de réprobation morale familiale
et il nous faut également saluer la
mobilisation à l'époque du sénateur
radical Henri cavaillet cayavet pardon
disparu en début d'année pour mener ce
combat je veux aussi apporter mon
soutien à toutes celles et tous ceux qui
souffrent encore de ne pas se sentir
libre de dire et de vivre librement leur
orientation sexuelle dans son rapport
annuel SOS Homophobie alertait sur une
hausse sensible des agression physique
antillgbt une tous les deux jours alors
que des personnes politiques ont pu
encore récemment tenir des propos
inacceptables consternant il n'est plus
que nécessaire de rester mobilisé
monsieur Bourgis vous êtes l'auteur de
la proposition de loi cignée avec des
sénatrices et des sénateurs de tous les
bancs dont nous discutons cet après-midi
elle vise plus de 40 ans après à
reconnaître et à apporter la réparation
aux personnes condamnées sur cette
période avec les membres du groupe RDPI
nous voterons pour vous souhaitez chers
collègues que la France reconnaisse sa
responsabilité dans la politique de
criminalisation et de discrimination
contre les personnes homosexuelles comme
l'ont déjà fait d'autres pays l'Espagne
il y a 16 ans le Canada et l'Allemagne
plus récemment 2017 et l'Autriche cette
année vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
rapporteur le législateur s'est fourvoyé
en soumettant l'homosexualité à la loi
pénale au regard de difficultés
juridiques touchant d'une part au
système de réparation proposée d'autre
part à la nouvelle infraction pénale
venant réprimer la négation ou la
minoration ou transancière de la
déportation des homosexuels pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale qui déjà prise
en compte dans le droit actuel il est
proposé cet après-midi un dispositif qui
se veut consensuel nous nous soutenons
cette démarche collective 40 ans durant
des hommes ont été traités comme des
criminels et condamnés à vivre
clandestinement leurs relations alors
même que notre pays avait été précurseur
à l'échelle mondiale après une première
dépénalisation en
1791 en 2022 auprès du magazine Têtu
ellisabeth borne s'y était engagée nous
devons avancer pour réparer ce qui peut
l'être c'est ce que nous nous apprêtons
à faire en conclusion je veux saluer
l'action de la diplomatie frça en faveur
de la dépanalisation dans le monde elle
fait de la protection des droits de des
personnes LGBT plus une priorité alors
que 69 pays criminalisent encore
l'homosexualité 11 d'entre eux prévoyant
d'ailleurs la peine de mort parmi les
plines applicables on ne doit pourtant
jamais être coupable de qui on est pour
reprendre les propos d'un homme tenu
dans un reportage homosexualité les
derniers condamnés aujourd'hui le Sénat
sera au rendez-vous je vous rem merci
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à Madame Audrey Lincoln held
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 6
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur l'auteur chers collègues on
peut se demander avec le recul comment
des députés français c'est-à-dire par
définition des femmes et des hommes qui
devrai avoir l'intelligence de nos
libertés fondamentales puisqu'ils sont
chargés de les défendre ont pu légiférer
pour réprimer l'homosex l'homosexualité
voilà ce que disait Giselle Alimi à la
fin de l'année
81 on peut en effet se le demander se
demander pourquoi ces lois qui ont
pénalisé l'homosexualité arrivent au 20e
siècle alors même que depuis la
Révolution française les relations entre
personnes consentantes de même sexe
avaient été
décriminalisées certes c'est une loi de
1942 sous Vichi qui a réintroduit le
délit d'homosexualité dans la
législation française et qui a introduit
en même temps la référence à des actes
impudiques ou contrenat
oui c'est donc une loi de 42 mais on le
sait la réflexion a été entamée bien
avant sous la 3e république et pire le
délit d'homosexualité survie à la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et à la
disparition du régime de Vichy car à la
Libération si l'ordonnance de 1945
transfèt ce délit d'un article du code
pénal vers un autre elle maintient
l'incrimination d'actes contre nature et
elle fait même de l'homosexualité une
circonstance aggravante en cas d'outrage
public à la pudeur la condamnation
juridique se renforce encore en 1960
avec l'adoption de l'amendement mirget
qui assimile l'homosexualité à un fléo
social quelle que soit la manière et les
termes utilisés et n'en déplaisent au
rapporteurs qui préfèrent retenir 1945
il ne fait pas de doute que de 1942 à
1982 soit pendant 40 ans la loi la même
loi est venue cautionner et conforter
toutes les oppressions dont sont
victimes les personnes homosexuelles et
que la Révolution française n'avait pas
fait disparaître ce que nous voulons
avec husseain Bourgie et l'ensemble du
groupe socialiste écologiqu et
républicains ainsi que tous les
signataires de cette proposition de loi
c'est au-delà de l'amnistie et de
l'abrogation porté par les socialiste
avec François mitteran et Robert
batanter en 1981 et 82 c'est reconnaître
et regretter avec l'article 1 évidemment
que le législateur s'est fourvoyé en
soumettant l'homosexualité à la loi
pénale mais qu'au-delà le législateur du
20e siècle a bien contribué à briser des
vies et a ainsi commis une faute non
seulement plusieurs milliers de
personnes ont été condamnées à des
amendes à de l'emprisonnement mais elles
ont été livrées à la vindicte populaire
et à l'exclusion sociale en raison de la
publicité associée à leur condamnation
je peux C citer ici l'exemple de cet
élève avocat lillois qui a eu son
concours en mai s'est fait condamné en
juillet et de ce fait n'a jamais pu
exercer faute d'avoir été accepté par le
Barreau et il s'est vu contraint de
renoncer au métier de ses rêves pour
devenir surveillant dans un lycée son
matisme professionnel et social a sans
doute été bien plus important que
l'amonde qu'il a eu à payer et la prison
qu'il a eu à connaître mais réparer ce
qui peut l'être doit l'être c'est
pourquoi nous tenons à ce que cette
proposition de loi comprenne aussi au
côté de la reconnaissance des mesures
claires de réparation comme celle
proposé dans les articles 3 à 5 le coût
de ces réparations serait limité au
regard du faible nombre de personnes
encore vivantes parce que le temps est
passé par là et parce que le sida aussi
est passé par là mais l'impact de
l'octroit de ces réparations sera quant
à lui très fort pour les personnes pour
les familles pour les homosexuels qui n
qui regardent la France partout dans le
monde nous restons donc au groupes
socialistes très attachés à la
réparation au cas par cas des torts
causés même si on peut discuter des
modalités d'application de la même
manière nous restons attachés à la
reconnaissance d'un délit spécifique lié
à la négation de la déportation de
personnes en raison de leur
homosexualité non il ne s'agit pas là
d'une légende mais d'une vérité
historique établie et rappelée par des
présidents de la République françaises
et comme tel sa négation ou sa
minimisation doit pouvoir être
sanctionné ce qui n'a pas été le cas
jusqu'à présent et monsieur le
rapporteur
indivisibilité ne doit pas dire
invisibilité il est d'ailleurs
regrettable que sur ces sujets qui ne
font pas consensus il n'ait pas été
possible d'organiser davantage
d'audition la parole et l'expertise
d'historien de sociologues et d'autres
juristes aurait été précieuse pour nous
éclairer je remercie pour ma part les
universitaires lillois Florence Tamagne
et Sébastien landendriilleux qui ont
partagé avec moi leurs travaux et je
veux dire la fierté de notre groupe que
cette proposition de loi déposé un 6
août non pas 1942 mais 2022 porté par un
socialiste Husain Bourgie puisse être
examiné aujourd'hui et je l'espère voter
ensuite à nous ici sénateur et
sénatrices du 21e siècle de laver le
déshonneur et les torts causés par
diverses lois du 20e siècle le Sénat a
failli être en avance sur l'Assemblée
nationale en
1978 il peut se rattraper aujourd'hui
pour montrer à nouveau la voix cette
fois-ci avec succès en votant cette PPL
dans toutes ses dimensions pour qu'elle
puisse ensuite êtreise à l'Assemblée
nationale à nous ici d'apporter les
excuses la reconnaissance la réparation
de la République à des milliers d'hommes
et des centaines de femmes punis
simplement pour ce qu'il les elles ét à
nous avec cette loi mémorielle car sen
est unee monsieur le ministre l'a
rappelé de faire un pas de plus vers
l'égalité des droits dans la société
j'invite donc tous les groupes
politiques l'ensemble des sénateurs et
sénatrices à entendre les histoires et
les voix de ces condamnés et dans la
discussion qui va s'ouvrir à dépasser
les argues juridiques ou les postures
politiques pour adopter notre
proposition de loi dans son acception
large pour que demain aucune Giselle
animie ne puisse plus jamais se demander
comment des parlementaires ont pu
pénaliser une liberté fondamentale celle
d'aimer merci chers collègues la parole
est à présent notre collègue Muriel
Jourda pour le groupe les républicains
pour 6
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues il
m'appartient de donner l'avis et
d'expliciter le vote du groupe les
républicains sur cette proposition de
loi qui a été déposée par notre collègue
de la commission des lois Husen Bourgis
et est signé par un certain nombre voire
à nombre certains de de nos collègues
ici vous avez compris que cette
proposition de loi était fondée sur deux
faits le premier et la déportation des
personnes homosexuelles pendant la la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et les
traitements qui leur ont été infligés
euh le second est euh le traitement
différencié dans les lois pénales de
l'homosexualité puisque ainsi qu'il l' a
été indiqué l'homosexualité était
considérée comme une circonstance
aggravante dans le cadre de l'outrage à
la pudeur et l'homosexualité a aussi été
pénalisée euh dans les relations entre
les mineurs de 16 ans à la majorité mais
elle était seule pénalisée puisque
l'hétérosexualité ne l'était pas il y a
donc un traitement
différencié ce que nous propose l'auteur
de la proposition de loi et d'abord de
reconnaître un un délit de négationnisme
euh pour ceux qui niraient la réalité
des faits infligés aux personnes
homosexuelles pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et ce qui nous est aussi
proposé et
d'indemniser les personnes qui ont été
victimes de cette discrimination par
application de la loi pénale ce que nous
propose notre rapporteur et je dirais
euh différent tout en
reconnaissant ce principe primordial qui
est celui du texte qui nous est proposé
c'est-à-dire la réalité de la
discrimination qui a été subi par les
personnes homosexuelles ce que nous
propose notre rapporteur d'abord c'est
de considérer que ce délit de
négationnisme il existe déjà et qu'il
serait même dangereux au regard des
procès en cours et au regard de ce que
nous pouvons estimer être les les droits
de l'homme et l'indivisibilité des
droits de l'homme de l'admettre le
groupe les républicains le suivra sur ce
point ce qu'il nous propose s'agissant
de la reconnaissance de la
discrimination c'est bien évidemment de
l'acter mais de ne pas permettre
l'indemnisation je suis pour ma part
assez convaincu des arguments qui ont
été avancés qui tiennent à la fois la
prescription et au fait aussi que il
soit difficile de condamner l'État pour
l'application de la loi tout simplement
puisqu'il n'y a pas d'autres
effectivement d'autres reproches qui
puissent être fait que l'application de
la loi s'agissant de des circonstances
particulières qui justifieraient d'un
préjudice et il nous propose aussi et là
aussi le groupe les républicains le
suivra de différencier la période du
régime de
Vichy régime pour lequel la République
n'a pas à s'excuser et là-dessus nous le
suivrons aussi c'était d'ailleurs une
période sensiblement différente puisque
l'homosexualité était pénalisée dans le
cadre précisément de ce ce ce ce grand
projet d'envergure qui était celui du
National Socialisme et qui se traduisait
par la déportation des personnes
homosexuelles au même titre que les
Juifs au même titre que les zigal donc
nous suivrons l'ensemble des
préconisations du rapport orteur et nous
voterons l'ensemble de ces amendements
pour aboutir à une loi qui effectivement
met en valeur le fait que il y a eu il a
existé une discrimination dans la loi
française pour les personnes
homosexuelles mais je crois et de ce
point de vue je m'associerai à la fois
au propos du rapporteur mais également à
ceux de Monsieur le gardessau qu'il est
difficile effectivement de
juger le présent ou le passé avec les
yeux du présent et et pour ceux qui ont
la curiosité de se pencher sur la
lecture des débats qui ont pu avoir lu
au Séné en 1982 c'est assez c'est assez
flagrant dans la forme comme dans le
fond dans la forme d'abord parce que il
a été indiqué à plusieurs reprises que
la dépénalisation de
l'homosexualité est intervenu en 1791 et
bien au Sénat en 1982 on pouvait
s'interroger sur le fait que cela
existait parce que cambaseres lui-même
avait cette orientation sexuelle débat
que nous n'aurions plus aujourd'hui dans
cet hémicycle était rappelé aussi des
choses assez intéressantes sur ce qu' a
pu être la société notamment en 1945
lorsque le général de Gaulle a pu
reprendre cette infraction par une
ordonnance qui codifiait le code pénal
cette ordonnance elle avait été examinée
en conseil des ministres et à l'époque
vous le savez le Conseil des ministres
était pour le moins Bigaré politiquement
et nous étions tous représentés dans ce
conseil des ministres et effectivement
personne n'avait protesté parce que tout
simplement c'était l'état de la morale
de la société à cette époque alors je
crois qu'il ne faut pas ignorit l'état
de la morale de la société et l'État de
la morale de la société à notre
époque nous pourrions le
résumer
allez sur les bancs de cette assemblée
de ce côté-ci il nous a été beaucoup
reproché pendant le le débat sur le
texte sur l'immigration de ne pas avoir
assez cité le pape François et bien je
vais vous faire plaisir mes chers
collègues je vais vous citer le pape
François qui parlant d'homosexualité a
indiqué très clairement qui sommes-nous
pour juger
et je crois qu'effectivement c'est ainsi
que nous pouvons résumer l'état de la
société aujourd'hui qui sommes-nous pour
juger et d'ailleurs que jugerions-nous
l'homosexualité ça fait partie de la
personnalité ça fait partie de la vie
privée et il ne revient pas à quiconque
et surtout pas à l'état de discriminer
qui que ce soit pour cet élément de sa
vie privée et c'est pourquoi le groupe
les républicains votera bien évidemment
la version amendée de ce texte je vous
remercie merci la parole est à présent
monsieur Joshua
ochochard pour les sénateurs ne figurant
sur la liste d'aucun groupe pour 3
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
l'omophobie perdure en France et nous
regrettons souvent que ces causes soient
souvent et délibérément ignorées nous
devons lutter collectivement contre ce
fléo qui se trouve partout au travail
dans nos rues dans nos établissements
scolaires mais surtout dans certains
quartiers où un grand nombre de nos
jeunes sont harcelés par pour une
orientation sexuelle réelle ou
supposé chaque jour des couples de même
sexe n'ent pas se promener dans la rue
en se tenant la main d'autres doivent
cacher leur identité et vivre leur amour
ou leur sexualité dans la clandestinité
en 2022 mais ça a déjà été rappelé nous
avons ainsi connu une hausse de 28 % des
actes anti LGBT néanmoins si le Prin de
réparation des personnes discriminées du
fait d'une égalité de droit qui a
perduré pendant la période visée est
parfaitement entendable et sur lequel
nous sommes plutôt favorable certains
points vient de gâcher ce texte d'autre
part d'une part pardon l'article 1 qui
évoque la responsabilité de la France
comme si les français étaient
responsables des erreurs de leurs
dirigeants enfin c'est encore une
manière d'amalgamer l'État français de
Vichi à l'ensemble du peuple français
quand les historiens s'accordent à dire
que Vichi ce n'était pas la France qui
elle vivait sous le jou nazi était
victime de le er concentrationnire ou
exterminatrice ou se batter contre
l'occupant
allemand par ailleurs il ne faut pas que
cette proposition de loi qui répond un
légitime souhait d'indemnisation soit le
prétexte pour ne pas répondre à
l'homophobie de notre époque celle qui
trouve majoritairement ses sources dans
islamisme qui vise aussi bien les femmes
les Juifs que les homos je vous
remercie merci la discussion générale
est close la commission n'ayant pas
élaboré de texte nous passons à la
discussion des articles de la
proposition de loi initiale à l'article
1 je suis saisi de plusieurs demandes de
parole à commencé par Madame Hélène
conouet
Mouret merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
j'aimerais avant l'examen des articles
et des amendements revenir sur les
points essentiels qui m'ont incité dans
un premier temps à à signer cette
proposition de loi et vous inviter
maintenant à à la soutenir la France a
connu ses lumières et prise de liberté
et d'égalité elle fut le premier pays au
monde à supprimer les infractions
réprimant l'homosexualité en 1791 elle a
aussi sé par d'ombre la loi pénalisant
l'homosexualité prise sous le régime de
Vichy est malheureusement confirmé à la
Libération a conduit à la condamnation
de plusieurs milliers de personnes
jusqu'au loi d'amnistie en 1981 puis
d'abrogation en 82 la proposition de loi
portée par notre collègue Hussein Bourgi
nous permet de tourner enfin ces pages
sombres de notre histoire nationale et
reconnaître les erreurs commises par nos
prédécesseurs et en conséquence les
réparer elle permettrait à notre pays de
s'inscrire dans le mouvement des nations
et à des gens emprunter cette voie
courageuse je pense à l'Allemagne dont
le trisème rche a fait des milliers de
victimes condamnées pour l'homosexualité
à l'Espagne dont le régime franquiste
s'est engagé dans la lutte contre
l'homosexualisme ou encore au Canada et
ont tous trois instauré des réparations
financières à l'instar de ce que propose
ce texte ayant l'audace de suivre ces
exemples à l'heure où partout dans le
monde les droits sociaux les plus
élémentaires sont remis en cause en
décembre 1981 au côté de Robert bernater
Giselle Alimi se demander comment avec
le recul les députés français
c'est-à-dire par définition des hommes
et des femmes qui devraient avoir
l'intelligence de nos libertés
fondamentales puisqu'ils sont chargés de
les défendre ont pu légiférer pour
réprimer l'homosexualité je souhaite
aujourd'hui que nous fassions preuve de
cette intelligence que nous tendions la
main à ceux qui ont été injustement
marginalisé et laissé et laisé pardon le
Sénat peut envoyer aujourd'hui un
message de tolérance et de respect à
notre société que je crois en quête
d'apaisement c'est la raison pour
laquelle je voterai sans réserve en
faveur de cette proposition de loi et
vous invite à faire de même merci la
parole est à présent au président Pierre
ououias merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mais mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi porté
sur une période à l'ANT 200942 à 1982
monsieur le rapporteur vous nous
proposez de réduire cette période en
sortant Vichy de son champ d'application
et je vous cite vous considérez que le
régime de Vichy ne paraît pas pouvoir
être valablement pris en compte or chers
collègues je me permets de vous signaler
que le Parlement a voté à l'unanimité la
loi du 23 juillet 2023 qui porte
reconnaissance d'espoliation antisémite
commise par l'état français du 10
juillet 1940 au 24 août
1944 il ne peut pas y avoir chers
collègues de réparation des crites
commis par Vichy sans reconnaissance des
lois de Vichy il serait totalement
incompréhensible que le Parlement
reconnaisse l'espoliation antisémite qui
font l'objet de restitution et
d'indemnisation et pas les persécutions
commises par le même régime contre les
homosexuel certes chers collègues vichis
n'était pas la République mais c'était
un régime à la tête duquel le maréchal
Pétin a obtenu les pleins pouvoirs et à
l'époque 569 parlementaires avaient voté
pour et 80 avaient voté contre merci à
ces 80 qui avaient voté contre merci
monsieur le
Président merci monsieur
Lurel merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je voudrais sans
hésiter ce texte de notre collègue husin
Bourgin mais j'aimerais réagir à ce qu'a
dit monsieur le ministre que il faudrait
au préalable qu'il y ait une
condamnation par une un tribunal ou une
instance internationale et en général on
évoque
neurber on m'a opposé la même chose
lorsqu'on a voulu reconnaître la
négation du génocide arménien on nous a
opposé également la même chose lorsqu'on
a voulu donner une prescription
normative à la loi mémorielle tobira il
est possible et j'ai entendu une de nos
collègues de le dire c'est une
jurisprudence de la Cour de cassation
qui empêche de reconnaître un délice
spécifique notamment en de l'orientation
sexuelle donc la ce que notre rapporteur
a exposé en disant qu' a presque une
impossibilité juridique imposé par une
jurisprudence absolument réactionnaire
de la Cour de cassation il est possible
de créer ce dél spécifique lorsque il y
a les injustices qui ont été commises en
raison de l'orientation sexuelle c'est
un bon
Sexte merci Madame
SIS
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues l'homophobie
tue et le silence aussi la pénalisation
de l'homosexualité en France a tué y
compris après son abrogation oui la
République que ce soit celle de Vichi
jusqu'à la 5e doit le reconnaître et
réparer le préjudice causé par ces lois
parce que sinon sinon cela cela ne
s'arrêtera pas les morts ne s'arrêteront
pas juin 92 plus de 10 ans déjà après
les premières détections de ce qui sera
appelé le cancer gai pour la première
fois j'aiécris dans le journal du sida
c'était le numéro 40 page 51 du numéro
une intervention du magistrat Yve jouau
président du fond d'indemnisation des
hémophiles et des transfusés contaminés
par le VIH déjà la question de
l'indemnisation est posé page 5
j'écrivais inutile de cacher les toxicos
et les homos 4 82 1 an après que le
premier article de presse relatif au
sida paraît dans le New York Times la
France dépénalise l'homosexualité trop
tard la la stigmatisation perdure et
l'épidémie s'installe double
condamnation condamné pour homosexualité
condamné à mort par une épidémie que
l'homophobie d'État n'a pas voulu
reconnaître et combattre à temps les
communautés
LGBTQI plus savent ce que le VIH leur
appr pris et nous savons ce que nous
devons à la santé communautaire pour
rétablir la justice face au préjudicees
créés par ces lois de criminalisation et
de discrimination de celles qui de facto
ont conduit à des peines de mort massiv
je voterai évidemment en faveur de cet
article et de cette proposition après
cette première pierre contre les
discriminations pour suivons cette
politique mémorielle mais aussi de
réparation sans purge de l'histoire et
souvenons-nous de ce que nous devons y
compris aux combattantes et aux
combattants du sida je vous remercie
merci Monsieur
Pomier monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des saau mes chers collègues je
voudrais souligner que les résistants
homosexuels n'ont guerre été honorés par
la nation et qu'il y a matière ce soir à
leur rendre aussi justice le rapporteur
a rappé dans son propos le nom de Jean
desborde qui illustre ce manquement
l'écrivain Jean desborne unant compagnon
de Jean coctau est entré dans la
Résistance sous le nom de Duroc il est
mort surous la torture des nazis dans la
nuit du 5 au 6 juillet 1944 à 38 ans son
nom d'écrivain figure certes au Panthéon
parmi ceux des écrivains morts pour la
France mais rien pour le résistant Jean
desborde qu'il a été et qui en gardant
le silence sous la torture a protégé ses
compagnons et sauveré une partie de son
réseau francopolonais F2 Daniel Cordier
résistant et secrétaire de Jean Moulin a
d'ailleurs mis très longtemps avant de
révéler son homosexualité dans son
autobiographie la haine à l'égard de
l'homosexualité était terrible disait-il
alors ce texte ce soir est important il
est symbolique notre responsabilité
aussi pour rendre justice à ces
résistants homosexuels à travers un
texte de réparation et d'apaisement
merci merci chers
collègues à l'article 1er et je suis
saisi d'un amendement et d'un
sous-amendement je amendement de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
amendement numéro
1 monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Mesdames Messieurs chers
collègues je vais donc proposer
l'amendement suivant la République
française reconnaît sa responsabilité du
fait de l'application des dispositions
pénales suivantes à compté du 8 février
45 qui ont constitué une discrimination
fondée sur l'orientation
sexuelle suit la liste des infractions
visées elle reconnaît que ces
dispositions ont été source de
souffrance et de traumatisme pour les
personnes condamnées de manière
discriminatoire sur leurs
fondement
merci Monsieur Bourgier pour la
présentation du sous-amendement numéro 3
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues vous l'avez compris ma
préférence ne va pas à cet amendement à
cette mouture là mais si c'est celle-ci
qui devait être retenue je propose un
sous-amendement qui associe à la mouture
proposée par notre collègue rapporteur
la réparation je m'adresse à tous les
juristes et ils sont un certain nombre
ici je m'adresse aux pénalistes et il y
en a quelques-uns ici en droit français
lorsqu'on va devant le tribunal
lorsqu'on va devant les cours c'est pour
faire établir et reconnaître la
culpabilité de quelqu'un dès lors que la
culpabilité a été
retenue pour être cohérent pour être
logique il faut que le tort qui a été
infligé à quelqu'un que je préjudice qui
a été infligé au plaignant soit
indemnisé j'entends les difficultés que
cela peut représenter pour trouver les
victimes mais justement la mouture que
je propose c'est que ce soit les
victimes qui se manifestent comme pour
l'archi ni plus ni moins le rapporteur a
soulevé un certain nombre d'objections
d'ordre juridique il se trouve que
d'éminents juristes que j'ai consulté
des spécialistes en matière de droit
pénal et y compris des spécialistes de
la haute assemblée qui m'ont assisté
dans la rédaction de cette proposition
de loi ne partage pas son point de vue
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle je
persiste et signe une reconnaissance
sans réparation on aurait franchi que la
moitié du chemin et si dans quelques
années on devrait revenir pour dire
finalement on va prévoir une réparation
qui ne serait jamais appliqué c'est
typiquement le genre de loi qu'on sait
voter que les parlementaires savent
voter et qu'on pour seul but de donner
bonne conscience au parlementaires parce
que les principaux concernés ne sont
plus en vie donc je vous propose ce
sous-amendement qui prévoit la
réparation pour que nous soyons
cohérents jusqu'au bout reconnaissance
et
réparation merci chers collègu avis de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
sous ce sousamendement numéro
3 en général je ne réponds jamais aux
lettres anonyme donc lorsque vous me
citez d'éminents juristes je suis sûr
que ils pourront se manifester
clairement indiquer leur nom et les
arguments maintenant quand vous allez
devant un tribunal il se trouve qu'il y
a des règles la première c'est la
prescription civile ça existe et donc
que la prescription est acquise vous
trouverez toujours des juristes et s'ils
veulent se manifester auprès de moi
ouvertement je serai ravi de leur
répondre et je dis la prescription ça
existe la deuxième chose plus gravement
c'est que le préjudice résulte de quoi
il résulte à la fois de la loi pénale
mais c'est-à-dire que vous demandez à la
République d'indemniser l'application
par des juges d'une loi qui est une
mauvaise loi mais qui a été appliquée
par des juges la nature du préjudice la
vraie gravité du préjudice qui découle
de cette loi elle est le fait de la
société et donc elle ne résulte pas de
la loi directement donc ça poserait
aussi d'autres problèmes voilà pourquoi
je pense que cette réparation
aujourd'hui n'a pas de sens la
réparation elle est symbolique elle est
morale je me réjouis je me réjouis de
votre proposition de loi vous avez tiré
de l'oubli ces manquements de la
République mais je pense que la loi
mémorielle
suffit merci monsieur le rapporteur avis
du gouvernement l'avis est défavorable
évidemment avis du gouvernement sur
l'amendement et le sous-amendement
monsieur le ministre merci merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure sont des avis de sagesse
que le gouverne
veut Texprimer l'important c'est un
texte le gouvernement n'entend pas
entrer dans dans dans dans dans les
dissensions et encore le mot est mal
choisi à l'évidence
euh voilà avite sagesse et je
n'exprimerai c'est assez rare que le
gouvernement ne s'exprime qu'insi je
n'exprimerai que des avis de
sagesse
pardon non non monsieur darmana n'a rien
à voir làdedans moi c'est du pomorti
voilà ah oui il a fait ça la semaine
dernière je savais pas merci monsieur le
ministre je suis saisi de plusieurs
demandes de parole à commencé par Madame
Rossignol merci monsieur le Président
j'avoue que le l'amendement présenté par
le rapporteur pose beaucoup de problèmes
son intention j'imagine est de protéger
la République qui pourrait être par une
lecture rapide assimilée à la période de
Vichi et vous voulez protéger la
République mais pour se faire en fait
vous effacez ce qu'on subit les
personnes homosexuelles en France
pendant la période de Vichy vous effacez
ce qu'a très bien évoqué il y a un
instant votre collègue Pomier notre
collègue Pomier qui eux ne seront pas
visés par ce texte donc d'une main
protég République mais je reviendrai pas
sur les propos du président Chirac moi
je cite pas je ne cite pas Jacques
Chirac continuellement mais enfin je
cite le président de la République parce
que il a fait ce jour-là dans ce propos
un acte important pour la déportation
des Juifs nous avons l'occasion de faire
le même et puis aussi désagréable que ce
soit il y a des politiques qui ont connu
une grande continuité entre Vichi et la
4e République je vais vous en citer une
la politique de criminalisation et de
pour suite des femmes qui avortaient
cette politique a conduit souvichi à
aller jusqu'à la peine de mort mais elle
ne s'est pas arrêté la peine de mort a
été supprimée mais elle ne s'est pas
arrêté avec la 4e République elle s'est
même intensifié puisqueà partir de 46
les femmes qui recouraient à des
avortements étaient poursuivies et voire
même toutes les structures mises en
place sous Vichi pour les identifier ont
été renforcé donc c'est des agréable à
entendre mais des politiques moralistes
celles qui visent à pénaliser les droits
sexuels et reproductifs ceux des femmes
comme ceux des homosexuels ont connu une
continuité par ailleurs le texte de
notre collègue ne parle pas de
responsabilité c'est vous qui qui
introduisait la notion de responsabilité
le texte de notre collègue dit la
République français reconnais et
reconnaît et regrette elle ne dit pas
qu'elle est responsable mais vous en
voulant dire qu'elle est responsable
vous excluez les homosexuels qui ont été
porté qui ont sou souffert s Vichi merci
madame de La
Gonterie merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues euh
l'amendement que propose le rapporteur
n'a qu'une vocation c'est d'exclure la
période du Vichi ça a été euh rappelé
par notre collègue et par Pierre
ououlias quel était le le
contresens alors sans doute pour faire
un bon mot le rapporteur dit ah mais la
gauche cite jaces shirac mais moi je ne
cite pas JAC Chirac je cite le président
de la République et quand le 16 juillet
95 il dit reconnaître les fautes du
passé c'est défendre une idée de l'homme
de sa liberté et de sa dignité lorsqu'il
dit cette phrase historique oui la folie
criminelle de l'occupant a été secondée
par les Français secondée par l'état
français lorsqu'il dit reconnaître les
fautes du passé les fautes commises par
l'État ne rien occulter desors sombres
de notre histoire c'est tout simplement
défendre une idée de l'homme de sa
liberté de sa dignité c'est lutter
contre les forces obscures sans cesse à
l'œuvre c'est cela que nous vous
demandons aujourd'hui nous vous
demandons pas de d'avaliser de quelque
manière que ce soit ce qui s'est passé
sous Vichi nous demandons que nous le
prenions en compte et donc il y a une
curiosité tout de même mais j'ai vu que
vous aviez prudemment demandé un scrutin
public ainsi nous pourrons chacun
prendre des responsabilités il y a quand
même une curiosité à vouloir effacer de
notre mémoire collective et de notre
responsabilité collective cette période
de l'histoire et c'est pour cela que je
citais le président de la
République
merci président
zulias merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mais mes chers
collègues monsieur le rapporteur vous
vous m'avez pas répondu sur le parallèle
que je fais entre votre votre propos
position d'amendement et la loi du du 23
juillet 2023 chers collègues cette loi
du 23 juillet 2023 nous l'avons voté
ensemble et contre la vie du
gouvernement le gouvernement à cette
époque là souhaitait confondre la
responsabilité de Vichy et la
responsabilité du Reich allemand et
c'est dans cet hémicycle et je me
souviens très bien de mon collègue Max
Brisson et de sa défense et de Monsieur
carucci et de sa défense extrêmement
forte pour que le Parlement enfin
reconnaissent les lois de Vichy parce
qu'elles sont pas distinctes de ce qui
s'est passé après et donc là chers
collègues en votant l'amendement de
notre abanteur vous revenez vous revenez
sur un pas historique du Parlement sur
quelque chose qui a été voté à à
l'unanimité je vous demande vraiment de
faire attention parce que je pense que
en ce moment avec la montée des actes
antisémites ce que ce que vous allez
faire serait assez catastrophique merci
chers collègues
merci monsieur le rapporteur voulez
ajouter quelque chose
oui d'abord quand vous parlez de la
reconnaissance je je rappelle quand même
que sous Vichi on a confisqué des biens
qui étaient encore dans les musées
nationaux et qui appartenaient encore à
l'état ce qui expliquait peut-être que
on ait pu faire ça deuxièmement vous
faites vous-même la différence dans la
proposition de loi puisque vous
distinguez la période négationniste la
pour le négationiste période de Vichy et
la période post Vichy donc moi venir
dire que
j'fface venir dire que j'aifface la
répression des homosexuels en disant
c'est la République et j'oublie Vichi on
peut tout entendre mais c'est faux pour
moi le problème de la répression la
déportation des homosexuels elle est
réglée par Nuremberg il y a pas à
revenir dessus c'est un crime contre
l'humanité et personne n'entend le
minoré voilà donc à partir de ce
moment-là
je ve bienon soit taxé de révisionnist
deaire l'histoire la vérité c'est que le
Président de la République pardonnezmoi
ma
familiarité président de la République
ce qu'il dit il l'État français les
Français on il dit pas la France pas la
République parce quei n pas ça sera
jamais la
République merci Madame
L
merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais redire à notre rapporteur que
pendant la période de Vichy de 1942 à 45
il s'est passé deux choses différentes
il s'est passé la première qui est liée
à la pénalisation de l'homosexualité sur
le fondement du code pénal des articles
si je ne m'abuse 330 331 qui a conduit à
des condamnations à des amendes à des
emprisonnements c'est cela que vous
allez effacer en nous proposant de ne
retenir que la période de 45 à 82 ça
n'est pas la déportation ça c'est
l'autre élément qui s'est en effet passé
sous Vichy et pour lequel vous avez un
autre avis défavorable sur la création
du délit spécifique de négationnisme
mais là avec votre amendement c'est
l'ensemble que vous effacez que vous
ayez envie de de ne pas intégrer la
question du déli spécifique sur le
négtionisme on peut l'entendre c'est un
autre débat mais là ce que vous effacez
en même temps c'est le même délit celui
qui a conduit non pas nécessairement à
des départations et d'ailleurs les
chiffres le montre il y a beaucoup moins
de déportation que de condamnation sur
le le le pardon le fondement du code
pénal ce que vous effacez ce sont les
mêmes condamnations les mêmes
emprisonnements les mêmes amendes les
mêmes conséquences pour les familles que
celles qui qui auront lieu après
1945 merci mes chers collègues j'ai été
saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public sur cet
amendement et ce sous-amendement je vais
mettre au voix ce d'abord le
sous-amendement avec un avis défavorable
de la commission et un avis de sagesse
du gouvernement le scrutin est
ouvert
bien le
sousamandement
ne demande à
voter
si
on vote bien je le redis pour répondre à
ce que demandait madame de La Gonterie à
à raison on vote bien sous le
sous-amendement mais il y a un problème
de développement informatique et donc
c'est pour ça que vous avez inscrit sur
les écrans l'amendement mais il s'agit
bien du
sous-amendement ne demande à voter le
scrutin est donc
clos
résultat de ce scrutin sur le
sous-amendement numéro 3 votant
344 exprimé 321 pour 122 contre 199 ce
sous-amendement numéro 3 n'est pas
adopté toujours saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement numéro 1 de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur qui a fait
l'objet d'un avis de sagesse du
gouvernement le scrutin est
ouvert
demande à
votter
si
ne demande à voter le scrutin est
clos résultat du scrutin votant
344 exprimé 337 pour 221 contre 116
l'amendement numéro 1 est adopté et il
vaut adoption de l'article
1er à l'article 2 je suis saisi d'une
demande de parole madame audreé lincol
held c'est bon monsieur
Bourgi monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai
divergence majeure sur cet amendement
sur cet article avec le rapporteur et
avec ce qui a pu être dit tout à
l'heure le rapporteur a fait
systématiquement référence à
Nuremberg moi je vais faire référence à
ce qui s'est passé en France en 2012 un
député du Nord Christian vanest a évoqué
la déportation pour motif
d'homosexualité pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale en parlant de légende le
président du parti Jean-François Copé a
pris une décision courageuse dans les
heures qui suivaient en l'excluant du
parti des associations ont porté
plainte lorsque l'affaire a été jugée 2
ans plus tard en 2014 Christian vanest a
été
relaxé en 2022 à l'occasion de
l'élection
présidentielle un nouveau responsable
politique Éric Zemour a tenu exactement
les mêmes propos aujourd'hui une plainte
est déposée devant les tribunaux je l'ai
dit en commission des lois je le redis
ici dans l'hémicycle nous ne pouvons pas
attendre et espérer un éventuel
revirement
jurisprudentiel et je veux dire avec
beaucoup d'amitié et de respect à notre
collègue rapporteur avec lequel j'ai
particulièrement bien travaillé je
regrette qu'un certain nombre
d'associations qui font autorité en
France sur la déportation des
homosexuels pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale n'est pas été auditionné je
pense au Mémorial de la déportation
homosexuelle je pense aux oubliés de la
mémoire et je pense un certain nombre
d'historiens qui aujourd'hui se sentent
un peu mis à l'écart parce que si nous
avons ce débat aujourd'hui dans cet
hémicycle c'est parce qu'il y a eu des
chercheurs il y a eu des universitaires
qui ont été délibérément mis de côté
laissés à l'écart parce que nous avons
été pris par le temps donc je le dis ici
sans esprit polémique mais j'ai entendu
leur récrimination parce que j'en ai été
le réceptacle ils m'ont tous écrit
pensant que c'était l'auteur qui
décidait de qui il auditionnait ça n'est
pas le cas et je forme le vœux que lors
de la seconde lecture nous puissions
audition toutes ces personnes qui ont
des choses à nous
dire
merci il n'y a pas d'autres
demande de prise de parole je suis donc
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
monsieur le
Président simplement pour une question
d'ordre il est bien évident qu'à partir
du momentù nous avons adopté le Sénat
adopté
l'amendement de la commission qui
devient désormais article prer et
article unique dans l'objectif de la
commission c'est un vote contre les
articles suivants qui sont proposés dans
le
texte merci monsieur le rapporteur
vouliez ajouter quelque chose en ce qui
concerne les auditions vous savez très
bien ce n'est pas une mauvaise volonté
de la part de la Commission ce sont les
contraintte de temps quand vous parlez
du procès vanest j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que la relaxe de
monsieur vanest ne résulte pas d'une
décision de la Cour de cassation c'est
une décision de cour d'appel qui n'a
jamais été frappée pour vois donc sa
portée est quand même beaucoup plus
limitée que celle que vous voulez donner
par rapport aux procédures en
cours
merci je vous rappelle qu'il y a un une
demande de scrutin public sur cet
article
2 je vais donc ouvrir le
scrutin le scrutin est
ouvert
demande à
voter scrutin est
clos résultat de ce scrutin sur
l'article 2 votant 344 exprimé 306 pour
103 contre 200 3 cet article 2 n'est pas
adopté à l'article 3 je suis saisi d'une
demande de parole madame Lincoln held
oui merci monsieur le Président
simplement redire à l'occasion de de cet
article 3 ce que j'ai pu indiquer tout à
l'heure c'est-à-dire l'attachement du
groupe socialiste bien évidemment à la
reconnaissance des fautes commises à
l'occasion de ces lois mais demander
aussi en en même temps que la
reconnaissance la réparation nous avons
été plusieurs sur plusieurs bancs à
décrire les parcours de vie brisés de
fait de ces lois à décrire comment les
personnes ont eu à souffrir et elles
sont plusieurs milliers d'hommes et et
quelques centaines de femmes comment ces
personnes ont évidemment très mal vécu
les les amendes parfois très lourdes
qu'elles ont eu à à payer les
condamnations très souvent à de la peine
de prison mais comment aussi à côté de
ces amands et de ces emprisonnements
c'est finalement l'eauprre sociale qui
est tombé sur elle parce que ces
condamnations ont souvent fait l'objet
de publicité et que ce sont donc des
parcours de vie qui ont été brisés des
ruptures familiales personnelles
sentimentales professionnel avec tout un
certain nombre de conséquences qu'on ne
pourra évidemment jamais complètement
évaluer et dont évidemment on ne pourra
jamais complètement couvrir les dommages
mais nous sommes attachés à la
réparation symbolique et et au modalités
telles qu'elles ont été définies par
husseain Bourgie dans cette proposition
de loi je veux ajouter d'ailleurs à cet
égard en matière de réparation que cette
loi comme d'autres a souvent frappé
d'abord les plus fragiles et que ce sont
d'abord les classes populair que ce sont
d'abord les immigrés qui ont fait les
frais de ces condamnations parce que
quand on a des revenus modestes quand on
est dans une situation fragile
évidemment c'est plus difficile de se
payer un lieu de drague discret euh de
trouver un endroit où se cacher c'est
plus difficile parfois aussi de négocier
sa libération après une arrê une
arrestation musclée voilà donc c'est
pour toutes ces raisons que je voudrais
réaffirmer ici notre attachement
vraiment ferme et sincère à cette
réparation merci chers
collègues s'il n'y a pas d'autres
demande de prise de parole je vous
rappelle que j'ai également été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public sur
cette article
3 le scrutin est
ouvert
ne demande à
voter le scrutin est donc
clos sur l'article 3 votant 344 exprimé
322 pour 119 contre cet article 32 203
l'article 3 n'est pas
adopté à l'article 4 y y a-t-il des
demandes de prise de
parole je suis sai d'une demande de
scrutin public sur cet article 4 que je
vais mettre au voix en rappelant que si
cet article n'est pas adopté je
considérerai que le vote est le même
pour l'article 5 qui constitue un gage C
article 5 deviendrait en effet sans
objet du fait de la suppression des
articles 3 et 4 qui crée une charge
publique le scrutin est
ouvert
ne demande à
voter le scrutin est
clos résultat de ce scrutin public sur
l'article 4 votant
344 exprimé 325 pour cet article 119
contre 200 6 il n'est pas adopté et en
conséquence même vote pour l'article 5
sur
l'intitulé de la proposition de loi je
suis saisi d'un amendement numéro 2 de
la commission monsieur le
rapporteur merci avis du gouvernement
sagesse j'imagine monsieur le
ministre merci je suis saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public également
le scrutin ah pardon explication de vote
du président canner oui monsieur le
président monsieur le garde des saau
nous arrivons à la fin de de ce débat
qui aurait pu être plus consensuel le
texte présenté par Monsieur Hussein
Bourgi avait une cohérence
reconnaissance et
réparation il fallait je pense selon
nous en tout cas garder cette cohérence
j'ai entendu les explications du du
rapporteur mais nous sommes y compris
sur une que symbolique en la matière et
il aurait été utile je pense pour le
Sénat d'être dans une phase de
reconnaissance qui aurait permis
finalement à notre Haute Assemblée
d'être parfaitement reconnu y compris
par toutes celles et tous ceux encore
vivants qui ont été frappés par ces lois
indignes de 42 et qui n'ont pas été
annulé cela a été rappelé à plusieurs
reprises par la 4e République j'aurais
donc une
simple suggestion à faire peut-être même
une question à poser au Garde des saau
monsieur le garde des saau nous allons
malgré la
déconstruction de ce texte de Monsieur
Bourgie euh soutenu par notre chef de
fil Audré lin Kenel et les autres
sénateurs et sénatrices du groupe
socialistes écologistes républicains une
suggestion c'est permettez-nous d'avoir
une continuité nous allons voter ce
texte même dans des conditions dégradées
euh obtenues par la majorité sénatoriale
par le biais des scrutins public mais
nous souhaitons qu'il puisse se
poursuivre qu'il puisse prospérer qu'il
puisse tranquillement aller à
l'Assemblée nationale nous interrogerons
d'abord bien sûr nos partenaires de
gauche à l'Assemblée nationale mais
monsieur le garde des saau peut-être que
vous pourriez imaginer puisque vous avez
reconnu la pertinence politique de ce
texte que du temps parlementaire soit
réservé pour l'examen du texte de
Monsieur Bourgi je pense que nous
progresserions et qu'il pourrait être à
nouveau enrichi d'amendements permettant
d'aller jusqu'au bout de la logique
initiale prévue par l'auteur ur de ce
texte voilà la question que je voulais
vous poser Mesdames et Messieurs mes
chers collègues nous voterons le texte
même dans ces conditions qui nous on été
imposé
merci je vais ouvrir le scrutin public
sur l'intitulé de la proposition de loi
le scrutin est
ouvert
ne demande à
voter le scrutin est
clos résultat du scrutin public sur cet
amendement numéro 2 votant
344 exprimé 341 pour 243 contre 98 cet
amendement est adopté je vais mettre au
voix à l'ensemble de la proposition de
loi y a-t-il des demandes d'explication
de vote sur l'ensemble du texte je n'en
vois pas demande de scrutin
public le scrutin est
ouvert
demande à voter le scrutin est donc
clos sur l'ensemble de ce texte intitulé
proposition de loi portant réparation
des personnes condamnées pour
homosexualité entre 1945 et 1982 votant
344 exprimé
343 pour
343 ce texte est ainsi
adopté je vais suspendre la séance pour
quelques
instants